hab mein name ist luca helfen die neuen
video auf meinem kanal und fahl machen
wir eigentlich das was an dieser stelle
herzlich willkommen heute zu einem video
mit julia noch nie auf meinen kanalstadt
genommen hatte alter und mit dreh wieder
leider schon häufig auf einem kanal
stattgefunden hat
wir kriegen hier eine bestrafung wie
meinen dickdarm ausgeräumt ist sieben
meter lang schlecht
ich hab sofort gesagt schlecht du bist
am 3
[Musik]
fertig lecker mit zwiebel erdäpfel
gelblich in der pfanne kohlenhydrate
nahrhaft kohlenhydrate hohe ecke
der kongress blogs kate winslet place
war mega projekt minecraft gewissheit
luca studien
nein ich hab auch schon bekommen
kenny drückt mit drucker einfach du
musst management mitarbeiter aktenordner
drucker an dem koffer schritt
aktenschrank computer edv system 10
central management organisierten meine
hand qual fliegenklatsche der üstra vom
töten von unschuldigen tieren zwiebel
essig todbringend
während hertha bsc mit einem bulli
kinder lehrer spielgeräte garten
spielzeuge sandkasten schwimmbad gibt
beschwingt kind gekehrt dingen gibt sich
bei ihm recht das war die frau schloss
die schule scheiße schulfach
hausaufgaben geometrie das matrix
algorithmen träger matratzen weil ich
eigentlich ist das ist sowieso
algorithmen war gründen hat er nichts
mit mathematik stimmt und auch aus
gründen die man berichtet dass keine
mathematik oder variable ja extra
funktionen die das ist haye noten
taschenrechner schulnoten
das ist dass ich habe ein jogger ja
leistungskursen mathe buch das eine
formelsammlung okay das war heute schon
ein enormer schlag eine art zahlen
gehört zahlen
[Musik]
das abbrechen
ein
[Musik]